الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
اك اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من
منطقه عسقلان في غلاف غزه اهلا بكم تصعيد
غير مسبوق في الصراع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
كتائب القسام تشن عمليه اطلقت عليها اسم
طوفان الاقصى شملت هجوما بريا وبحريا
وجويا وتسل لمقاومين الى مستوطنات عده في
غلاف غزه اسفر عن مقتل عشرات في صفوف جيش
الاحتلال واسر اخرين كما احكمت عناصر
القسام سيطرتها على عدد من مستوطنات غلاف
غزه في المقابل شن جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي غارات على مناطق مختلفه في
قطاع غزه ردا على عمليه طوفان الاقصى
معلنا حاله الحرب لاول مره
منذ سبعينيات القرن الماضي ومصادر طبيه
للجزيره تفيد باستشهاد نحو 200 فلسطيني في
قطاع غزه وجرح نحو 1ف شخص منذ صباح اليوم
في ردود الفعل الدوليه والعربيه دانت
امريكا وبريطانيا الهجوم واكدت وقوفهما
بجانب اسرائيل بينما حملت قطر مسؤوليه
التصعيد لاسرائيل وحدها بسبب انتهاكاتها
المستمره واقتحم المتكرره للمسجد الاقصى
كما طالبت روسيا ومصر والاردن والسعوديه
وعمان وغيرها الطرفين بوقف التصعيد وضبط
النفس الى
اللقاء